the girag an experience that's the thing
i was reading a lot of people you know
that we're sort of dividing the idea
that we're calling him crazy and they're
saying you know basically when I when a
a Muslim person bloke who kills a bunch
of people we start talking about the
calling them terrorists when a when a
you know a black dude kills a bunch
people we start calling them thugs but
when a young white guy starts killing
people we call them mentally ill and
somehow that's there's some inherent
hypocrisy and then I kind of just think
like it's I was thinking about this last
night like there's there's levels of
human evil that are so intense that will
we get when we approach them we just
kind of like shut down like you know
member the matrix when they would do
like the electronic pulse and all the
machinery would just shut down it's like
there are levels of human evil that we
get through that are so intense that
when we start approaching them thought
just drops out and pee in it's all
emotion that's lie and so you can look
at somebody like that and say you know
it's hypocritical to call that guy
mentally ill or you're fighting against
a feminist caused by not recognizing the
inherent misogyny in his attack but
really what's happening is something so
much sadder and deeper than either of
those things it's just like we're living
in this insane fucking world where human
beings have some tick in this country
more than in other countries no one can
figure out why where they sometimes once
in a while will go into a place and
shoot a bunch of people and no one knows
why it happens and some people say it's
because it's mental illness and some
people say it's cause of bad parenting
and some people say it's because of gun
control and some people say it's because
of you know violent video games and
violent men and MMA and movies and music
and nobody fucking knows why it's really
happening and it's so terrifying that we
just start slinging mud at one another
trying to trying to say well it's this
it's that and you're part of the problem
by perpetuating this idea and the
reality is is existence is terrifying
and humans are fucking weird and once
and well there's a evolutionary blip
that somebody pops out of their mother
with a you know sort of genetic code
ready to murder people and I don't think
it's because of being spoiled and maybe
it is and I don't think it's because of
you know chemical imbalances or maybe it
is it's just the reality is that's
what's happening is Jack the Ripper
exists in
you know point oooo 1% of human beings
it's terrifying I did the my audiobook
of my book and I wrote an article of
chapter about the trees and I had to
decide in there do i do Patrice's voice
or do I just do a regular voice so in
though so in when you buy the audio book
my book you hear me god damn part is
good that's not even a good and I was
like do I do that with all black people
like when I when will Smith talks do I
make him like I did it I did it it's
done Patrice is just so big with it he
so is you know his voice is so beggin he
was you kind of almost have to do it
because you know cuz you heard I was
telling it on Opie and Anthony but the
whole thing was that I dated / cerebral
palsy didn't know she had several palsy
cuz I was drinking so much and Patrice
thought that was fucking hilarious he
kept saying you would you want alcoholic
you can't even save someone disabled
part she disabled that is the worst
version but it's like if you do a Joey
Diaz impression you have to do it right
if you're gonna say something that joey
said you kind of have to say it
everybody does like everybody does if
they say something as Joey you don't
just say like if Ari has a joke you know
i might say it like as me i might tell
you all are he's got this great new joke
you know about buh buh buh buh buh
except if you're describing already mad
then you'll do the whole mumble mumble
mumble you do that you can't do that
what was your Will Smith boys tho same
exactly our boys hey know exactly is
Kobe Bryant boys I i wrote the N word in
the book twice and I was as white people
saying it and I didn't realize it cuz I
didn't fucking really pay much attention
to the editing of it I just wrote them
and then if the publisher like them I
was in and I was like I read it I was
like oh shit I gotta say the M word
knows if thinking for history i'll go
down as saying the word and despite
whether or not i've ever said it no
one's got me on record saying it so I
called my buddy Omar door see who's on
he's on he's pounding down I was like
hey can you come and read a passage of
my book and he's like oh I'd be honored
thanks oh my god so abrupt end to read a
passage with the l word on we know you
did because I was
to do this am I supposed to do this like
a white person I go pirate sounded that
way he's like you know I love you if I'm
getting you out of this one oh that is
so ridiculous yeah you should own up to
it in the book itself this is on the
audio book itself you would say well
there's a questionable word in this
passage so I brought in a good friend I
do I'll do you course yeah yeah fuck is
16 hours to read my own audio book I was
like oh my god can I cannot read out
loud to save my life